- Good morning, Believe Nation.
My name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe, and I believe
that entrepreneurs will solve all
of the major problems of the world.
So today's message is be patient.
Over to you, Simon Sinek.
(rooster crows)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- I talk to so many smart, fantastic,
ambitious, idealistic, hard-working kids,
and they're right out of college.
And they're in entry level jobs,
and I'll ask them, "How's it going?"
And they'll say, "I
think I'm going to quit."
And I'm like, why?
And they say to me, "I'm
not making an impact."
I'm like, you know you've
been here eight months, right?
(audience laughs)
They treat the sense of
fulfillment or even love
like it's a scavenger hunt,
like it's something you look for.
My millennial friends, they've
gone through so many jobs.
They're either getting fired.
I mean, it was mutual.
(audience laughs)
Or they're quitting because
they're not making an impact
or they're not finding the
thing they're looking for.
They're not feeling fulfilled as if
it's a scavenger hunt.
Love, a job you find joy from,
is not something you discover.
It's not like, I found love.
Here it is.
I found a job I love.
That's not how it works.
Both of those things require hard work.
You are in love because you work very hard
every single day of your
life to stay in love.
You find a job that
brings you ultimate joy
because you work hard every single day
to serve those around you,
and you maintain that joy.
It's not a discovery.
But the problem is this
sense of impatience.
It's as if an entire
generation is standing
at the foot of a mountain.
They know exactly what they want.
They can see the summit.
What they can't see is the mountain.
This large, immovable object.
That doesn't mean you
have to do your time.
That's not what I'm talking about.
Take a helicopter, climb.
I don't care.
But there's still a mountain.
Life, career fulfillment,
relationships are journeys.
The problem is this entire generation
has an institutionalized
sense of impatience.
And do they have the patience to go
on the journey to maintain
love, to feel fulfilled,
or do they just quit and on to the next.
Dump and on to the next.
Ghost and on to the next.
- I'm a big fan of modeled success.
I'm a believer that you
can shortcut your path
to success by finding what
other people have done
to achieve that success,
learning from them,
and applying it to your
own life, to your own path
to help you get there faster.
I love finding shortcuts.
I love finding hacks.
I love finding all the
productivity tools and team
and everything you can do to
climb that mountain faster.
But to Simon's point,
there is still a mountain.
There's still a lot of
work that has to go in.
It's working smart and working hard.
It's not just one or the other
to go and accomplish your goal.
If you look at my YouTube
channel as an example,
since we're watching here all together,
I've made 5,000 videos for this channel.
4,000 of them are public, and
1,000 plus of them are not.
They're practice videos.
They're demo videos.
They're test videos.
I sucked at the start.
Go back and watch my first
video, and look how bad it is.
Somebody recently left a
comment on one of my videos
I recorded five years ago, and she said,
"Oh, my Evan, look at how far you've come.
"Five years later, you
sound and look different
"in so many good ways."
And that's awesome to hear,
and also really frustrating.
You know, I am mostly the same Evan
that I was five years ago.
My belief system, my values, you know,
maybe I've learned a little bit more.
I've gained a little bit more experience.
But why am I so much better now on camera
than I was way back then?
Well, it's because I practiced.
What I had four, five years ago compared
to what I have now, the
difference is 5,000 videos.
You know, that 1,000 videos
that haven't been published,
those trying and errors and failings
on those 1,000 videos
that never got released
are more than what most
people ever create.
Most people who start a YouTube channel,
they'll make three, four, five, 10 videos
and quit 'cause it's too hard.
'Cause it's too challenging.
'Cause they don't want
to climb that mountain.
'Cause they don't want to put in the work.
Where here's 1,000 videos that
never saw the light of day
and 4,000 more that are going.
Now, can you get there faster than me?
Sure.
You know, I'm looking at Alex.
I'm lookin' at Lilly
who've been helping me
on some of the videos.
They are already better than when I was
when I first started.
They're already better than
I was maybe 1,000 videos in.
You can get there faster than me.
You can model success.
Maybe you also have just
more natural talent.
You can rise the ladder faster
than other people around you
if you have more natural
talent, if you model success,
if you have a deep passion
for what you're doing.
You can get there faster.
But it's still a long road.
You still have to be patient.
You still have to put in the work,
and I think that's what people
often get too frustrated by
is they want the immediate results.
They want the immediate success.
And if they don't get it, then they quit.
And so understand if this
is a deep passion of yours,
if this is something
that you want to commit
potentially the rest of your life to doing
because you care about
it so much, then expect
to suck at the start.
Expect it to take a lot of time.
Expect to work on trying
to improve your efficiency
and productivity and skills and resources
to get there fast as possible,
but expect to be committed.
And stay patient.
And if you are whether
it takes you 100 videos
or 5,000 videos or more of the
equivalent in your industry,
you'll get there.
So the question of the day today is,
I'm curious about your reps.
I'm curious.
How much are you putting
into your business?
How much are you practicing
daily to get better
at whatever skill it is you
have that you're bringing?
I'm curious about your schedule.
Leave it down in the comments below.
I'm excited to see what
you guys have to say.
I also want to give a
quick shout-out to Laytina.
Thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word.
It really, really, means a lot to me,
and I sincerely hope
you're enjoying the read.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
And I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
(typewriter clicks)
- So a bunch, a group of
really brilliant psychologists
in the field of expertise
research have sat down
and tried to figure out how
long do you have to work
at something before you
become really good, right?
And the answer seems to
be, it's an extraordinary
consistent answer in an
incredible number of fields,
and that is you need to have practiced,
to have apprenticed for 10,000
hours before you get good.
So every great classical
composer without exception
composes for at least 10 years
before they write their master work.
- Mozart 10?
- Mozart is composing at 11,
but he's composing garbage at 11.
I mean, he doesn't produce
something great until 22 or 23,
Concerto number nine, I think, to 71.
If I asked you how long did it take you
when you were doing this job
before you were comfortable
and good and what you were doing?
- 10 years at least.
- Yeah, 10 years.
- Yeah.
- And the same way with me.
I mean, it's an incredibly
consistent finding,
and it's really important because it says
that we are far too impatient with people
when we assess whether
someone has got what it takes
to do a certain job.
We always want to make that
assessment after six months
or a year or, and that's
ridiculous, you know.
The kinds of jobs we have people do today
are sufficiently complex.
They require a long time to reach mastery.
What we should be doing
is setting up institutions
and structures that allow
people to spend the time
and effort to reach master,
not judging them prematurely.
- Patience is for the impatient.
That, in fact, when
you're getting started,
and your in-laws are making faces at you
and you're not sure if
you're going to be able
to pay the rent and you don't know
why you're living in
Brooklyn to begin with.
You're going to have to
move back to Florida.
It's easy to say, you know what?
I need to go faster to
pick up these scraps,
to pick up these scraps.
And sometimes what that
does is it gives you
the foot up to get to the next level.
But sometimes what that does is
it just makes you a scrap collector.
And one of the things that we see
when we look at the work
of people who have put
really big ideas into the world,
who have built online platforms, right?
It's that they got there by
being patiently impatient
or impatiently patient, whichever way
you want to juxtapose it.
If you look around at the blogs you read
or the people you respect
online or the organizations
you want to work with, the
myth of the overnight success
is just that, a myth, that,
you know, the much vaunted
Twitter was a failure, a
complete failure for two years.
Nobody used it, and if
they took the mindset of
well, if it doesn't work
in two weeks, we got to go
go do something else, you
never would have heard of it.
- You know, China's a very special place,
and if you look at the big tech companies,
Apple's done very well.
Microsoft hasn't lost too much.
And Google's, you know, lost a lot.
So it's quite a bit of variation despite
all three of those being talented,
long-term oriented companies.
And when you look at Apple,
one of the amazing things
is when they did the iPhone.
They negotiated and talked
and built relationships
for six years before the iPhone
was allowed to come to
China so from 2005 to 2011.
And that took a lot of patience.
And now, that's one of
their largest markets
in the world for the iPhone.
And so what we take away from that
is a sense of great patience.
So it may be soon that we
have a license in China,
or it may take a couple of years.
But we're going to be very patient,
and we're looking forward
to a time, you know,
a decade or two decades from now
when the Chinese middle class will want
and embrace the kind of
content that we have.